tell us what inspired you want to write
this book storm focus well i noticed
that with each year that passed things
that require deep focus like reading a
book were for me getting harder and
harder it was getting more and more like
running up a down escalator you know
what i mean like i could do it but it
was getting harder
and
i just i was really uncomfortable with
what was happening and i was really
uncomfortable with the fact that it
seemed to be happening to everyone
around me and particularly the young
people in my life a lot of them seem to
be almost whirring at the speed of
snapchat right where nothing's still or
serious i'm really curious about talking
about your kids in this respect because
a lot of the book is about kids and i
want to figure out well is something
unusual happening to our attention and
if so what and what can we do about it
so i use my training in the social
sciences at cambridge university to
travel all over the world from miami to
melbourne to moscow to interview over
200 of the leading experts on focus and
attention and just really deeply dig
into their science to figure out what's
going on here
and i learned that there's scientific
evidence for 12 factors that can make
your attention better or can make it
worse and loads of the factors that can
make your attention worse have been
hugely rising in recent years we are in
a real and massive attention crisis i've
reached the conclusion just think about
some simple facts for every one child
who was diagnosed with attention
problems when i was seven and i think
we're pretty much the same age there's
now
100 children given that diagnosis and
that's because they're identifying a
real problem the average american office
worker
now focuses on any one task for only 65
seconds so we're sorry for only three
minutes for college students at 65
seconds so we're we're facing a real
problem here and i think what people
need to understand is if you're
struggling to focus and pay attention as
almost all of us are
your attention didn't collapse
your attention has been stolen from you
by some very big forces and once you
understand what's really happening to us
it opens up a different set of solutions
that we can all achieve together and
what are what is that who has who has
stolen it away from you so there's a
huge range of factors um and i'll give
you one example right you've got a phone
here and you might you might get some
messages on it assume it's about the
show right so i went to interview one of
the leading neuroscientists in the world
a guy named professor earl miller who's
at mit
and he said to me
there's one thing you've got to
understand about the human brain more
than anything else
you can only consciously think about one
or two things at a time that's it this
is a fundamental limitation of the human
brain the human brain hasn't changed in
40 000 years significantly ain't going
to change on any time scale any of us
are going to see you can only think
about one or two things at a time but
we've fallen for a massive delusion the
average teenager now believes they can
follow six or seven forms of media at
the same time but what happens is
scientists get people into labs and they
say okay do loads of things at the same
time and then monitor them and what they
discover is you can't do more than one
thing at a time what you do is you
juggle very quickly between them you go
from wait what was that facebook message
what did patrick just ask me what's this
on whatsapp what's on the tv over there
you juggle you juggle you juggle and it
turns out that comes with a huge cost
the kind of fancy name for it is the
switch cost effect when you switch
between tasks you think you're doing
lots of things at the same time so
you're talking to me you're looking at
your phone you're looking at the screen
it turns out you will do
everything you're trying to do less
competently
you make more mistakes you remember less
of what you experience you're far less
creative and this sounds like a small
effect when you first hear about it
you're like yeah i get that but that's
quite small it was shocking talking to
the scientists to realize what a big
effect this is so give you an example of
a pretty small scientific study that's
backed by a wider amount of evidence
hewlett-packard you know the printer
company
even the words paper jam make my whole
body [ __ ] tense up hewlett-packard
the printer company got a scientist in
to do some research on this and he split
their workers into two groups and the
first group was told just get on with
whatever your task is and uh you're not
going to be interrupted and the second
group was told get on with your task
you're going to have to answer a heavy
load of email and phone calls so pretty
much how you you me how we all live most
of the time right and at the end of it
they gave an iq test to both groups what
they discovered is the group that had
not been interrupted scored 10 iq points
higher than the group that had to give
you a sense of how big that is if the
three of us sat down now and smoked a
fat spliff together and got stoned our
iqs would go down by five points so
being interrupted all the time in the
way that we are is twice as bad for your
intelligence as getting stoned you'd be
better off sitting at your desk getting
stoned and doing one thing at a time
than you would sitting at your desk
being constantly interrupted and not
getting stoned to be clear you'd be
better off neither getting stoned nor
being interrupted obviously this is a
huge effect if you're interrupted
it takes on average 23 minutes to get
back to the level of focus that you had
before you were interrupted but most of
us never get 23 minutes spare so we're
constantly operating at this diminished
level of brain power a different study
found just getting eight text messages
an hour that doesn't sound like much to
me don't know if it does to you
that diminishes your ability to remember
what you're experiencing and to and to
answer questions about it by 30 this is
why professor miller said we are living
at the moment in a perfect storm of
cognitive degradation as a result of all
these interruptions so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]